this presentation is delivered by the
stanford center for professional
development
so before we begin allow me to introduce
um take let's take an opportunity to
introduce karissa little who you will
who you will be hearing from later today
carissa little is the director for
professional programs at the stanford
center for professional development
she has been with stanford university
for 10 years and is responsible for
collaborating with stanford faculty
industry experts and corporate partners
to develop the professional and
executive programs that extend stanford
to industry
she worked in both software and
education prior to coming to stanford
and now i'd like to turn over uh the
floor to professor bob sutton
bob sudden is a professor of management
science and engineering in the stanford
engineering school
sutton is also co-founder of the
stanford technology venture program and
the new hassel plattner institute of
design
which is a multi-disciplinary program at
stanford that teaches and spreads design
thinking
he is an ido fellow member of the
institute of the futures board trustees
and a professor of organizational
behavior
um at the stanford school of business
sun
studies links between managerial
knowledge and organizational action
innovation and organizational
performance he has received many honors
including
he was named one of the 10 b-school
all-stars by businessweek in 2007.
so with that let me turn it over to
professor bob sutton
thank you roni thank you roney so i'd
like to uh
welcome everybody out there on your
telephone staring at your screens in
various places in the world
and uh what we're going to do this
morning is talk a little bit about the
relationship between innovation and
action
in particular what i'm going to do is uh
go through some ideas that i've been
working on with various colleagues for
years
notably jeff effort my buddy huggy rao
who's going to be doing
the next webinar in november and a host
of doctoral students i especially a guy
named
andy harganon and um and let me
uh start out and give you kind of
what i would call a mental provisioning
a way of thinking that um that i often
use to frame
um to frame the innovation process both
with
my uh doctoral students in in research
crowds and especially with the companies
and managers and engineers that i work
with
and it's a real simple formula that i
stole from a business school professor
named charles o'reilly who's been
studying innovation for a good 50 years
and charles puts up this formula you'll
see here and it's this notion that if
you want to innovate
you've got to have kind of a one-two
punch of two things
first of all and this is something that
that i talk about a lot in my various
work in
in including the certificate program
that that you're
hearing about later one is creativity
that somewhere another
you've got to get new ideas now when we
think of creativity we tend to think
that well they're ideas that uh
we would develop ourselves or develop in
our organization and our team but one
thing that i always like to emphasize
is some of the most creative and
innovative organizations
get creativity in other ways they copy
it from other
other places classic way to be to be
creative that even steve jobs was famous
for saying
that geniuses steal or something like
that they don't just borrow
you can uh you can rent it like there's
creativity consulting firms
you can do a merger there's lots of ways
you can do creativity in a dif in
addition to do it
doing it yourself to bring something new
to your organization
or your team but one thing that i like
to say in this sort of like the hallmark
of what we're going to talk about today
is you can have the best ideas in the
world but if you don't implement them
well then they're fairly useless so um
at least useless to you so so what we're
going to do
is um sort of dig into this notion and
in particular
i'm going to be drawing on some ideas
from a book that my colleague jeff
heffer and i wrote you can see what i
consider one of my ugliest book covers
to the right i can tell you a whole
story about that
as an aside if you want to hear it um so
this is a book that
jeff pepper and i uh wrote sort of at
the height of the
the kind of the the last dot com boom
1990s late 1990s
that everybody was all breathless and
hypey about everything and talking about
what they were going to do
but one thing that we realized from
working with the various
companies various clients that we worked
with is that
knowing what to do is useless unless you
actually
do it so to go back to the formula in
the case of creativity
you can have the most creative ideas in
the world but if you don't implement
them in some way in your organization
they're actually i would say in some
ways worse than useless because uh well
you've got them but they're just sort of
just sitting there
and not doing anything and to give you
sort of a quick
example um which uh
oops i which i which i always think is
is great fun
so here's here's a sort of silly picture
this is from the um stanford campus
this is i i'm thinking well about eight
years ago
is when this happened and uh as ronnie
mentioned
um i'm one of the founders of something
called the hasso plattner institute
for design or a lot of people call it
the stanford d-school
and our whole philosophy at the stanford
d school is due to things so
what we tend to do with our students is
to sort of give them a kind of vague
assignment and say go into the world and
do something
so what we did was uh for those of you
who don't know about the stanford campus
it's a large campus
students ride their bicycles everywhere
and one of the hallmarks of the stanford
campus is there's actually a lot of
bicycle accidents
in fact there's a bicycle accident
virtually every day
and about 70 people a year are injured
enough badly enough that they go to the
emergency room and every now and then
somebody gets major brain damage so it's
actually a serious problem on campus
and um and what we did was we sent our
students out to
try to improve bike safety on campus not
to talk about it their job was to
actually do it
so what happened was the two student
groups and you see them pictures here
pictured here
actually met at something called the
intersection of death that's what the
students call it
it's kind of where two sort of downhill
paths
come together and there's always
pedestrians and
students smashing into each other there
at the intersection of death when you
show this to any stanford student they
recognize it immediately
and they did two things one of them came
with these signs you can see the folks
at the bottom
and the other ones set up a roundabout
just old-fashioned sort of roundabout
which hadn't been there
and one thing i do love about stanford
and maybe it's a little bit too precious
but
in many universities if the students
showed up and did this they would get in
trouble
but there's a truck you can see in the
background that's actually the student
um that's actually the stanford police
and they decided they should help
the students so you have the police
helping the students so i've got this
great video somewhere
the roundabouts working perfectly
everybody's happy they're going around
it safely
all right so they they had proof of
concept so this is creativity
now let's move to the next picture the
next picture is it actually turns out
i'm happy to report
that there's a roundabout there that's
the good news the bad news is
that it took stanford administration and
this was not for lack of money it had to
do with the bureaucratic issues that it
was not my job
had to do with people talking and it
took about seven years to actually put
this thing in place so
so sort of to you know to go back and
and do our comparison
that's creativity that's implementation
and this is really cute but if you don't
implement it it's kind of fun but it's
kind of useless so
so that's so that's uh i guess sort of
the message here
um to give you another example more in
the in the real world
and something that was much more
expensive some years back i worked with
a large fast food chain
that had a whole bunch of problems in
terms of quality service and cleanliness
and what they did was that they hired
one of those very expensive
management consulting firms and they
paid several million dollars
and they they had this report about all
these things that they should do to
improve
their operations to improve the way that
they
they made the food the way they
recruited people all the stuff
and so they have the presentation those
of you who have been to these
presentations final presentations
they're presenting it
and there was an older guy in the back
who raised his hand
and in his in his hand he had actually a
pile of powerpoint deck
a powerpoint deck and he said it's sort
of interesting that we bought
virtually the same report from one of
your competitors 10 years ago
and so the point is that they knew it
but they didn't do it
so that's another example and to do just
one more quick one i'm sure you're
getting the point by now
some years back uh mckinsey the renowned
consulting firm
did this study this is mostly with their
some of their major clients
and they ask a question for those of you
who are familiar with peter drucker's
work
one of peter drucker's main ideas is
that um
managers should be accountable for the
quality of people they should recruit
them they should develop them they
should fire and
uh criticize them if necessary and this
is something that almost it's hard to
disagree with so they asked this
question
should line managers be held accountable
for the quality of their people
well 78 of the corporate officers of
these large corporations said they
should seven percent reported they
actually did
so to us this is this is a classic case
of a knowing doing gap
of a situation where you have some new
ideas or some old ideas this isn't all
about creativity
and and the question is how do you
turn that knowledge into action so you
not only have in the case of innovation
the creativity
but you also have the implementation so
so what we're going to do
in our remaining i don't know 25 30
minutes whatever we have here
is um is i'm going to talk about
ways to overcome knowing doing gaps
situations where you have ideas but
you're not turning them into action
and um these ideas a lot of them are
developed in the knowing doing gap
in my uh new book good boss bad boss was
actually a new chapter on the smart talk
trap and i talk about this stuff a lot
on my on my blog as well
so so that's sort of the theme we're
going to dig into
is is how you overcome these problems
some of the and
and some of the root causes all right so
let's start the first one and this is
the one
that i've always had the most fun with
um it's especially fun to talk to law
firms and academics about this because
we
especially suffer from this problem so
this is
these are situations where people know
the smart the right thing to do
but they use talk as a substitute for
action and and let me
tell you where my colleague jeff effer
and i first
sort of noticed this and got interested
in this so this would be back i'm
guessing in about
2000 i had my first management
consulting
uh or my first consulting job with um
the top management team of a fortune 200
company
so across my life i up to this point
um i'd spend most of my time in academia
and had done a fair amount of field
research
but i'd never been led in to those sort
of sacred um
doors to see how the the captains of
industry perform their brilliant actions
and
and well i'm a stanford professor and
we're pretty inefficient in academia so
i figured these people would be much
better
well at least the team i studied had
incredibly weird dynamics
and i won't go into all of them but one
of the things they kept doing which
still amazes me was
uh they kept making these decisions and
they make the same ones over and over
again
but they never would actually implement
them and
probably i guess the worst or best
example depending on the way you put it
is they kept making the the decision to
put the name of their product on their
product
but from what i can tell they only
implemented this decision about a year
or two ago
and this was kind of a business to
business kind of product so it wasn't
immediately pressing but it was just
amazing to me
and it's a sign that if you will that
that hollow talk means nothing it's also
a sign for those of you out there you
should know and you do know that a
decision by itself
changes absolutely nothing so so my
colleague jeff buffer and i
got quite interested in this question of
well these were really smart people if
you looked at their resumes man they're
well educated they worked at the finest
firms or paid
a couple of them millions of dollars
what's going on so why would smart
people use talk as a substitute for
action and maybe in the q and a we can
talk about some of the details
but let me talk about um at least two of
the reasons um one of the first things
is
you can tell whether um sort of like
immediately whether
somebody is a smart talker and sort of
like the the moment you sort of have
contact with their glib if they're
entertaining if they're interesting
but whether they're actually good at
turning into action
um is a different sort of thing and on
top of that you've got this notion that
talk happens now
and you know we're trapped in the
perpetual present tense it seems like
action happens much later
worse yet there are some organizations
and i would nominate this
as among them and many teams of course
where tomorrow never comes
where essentially the way that you get
ahead in the organization
is by saying smart things not doing
smart things
and uh since this is political season
and we're listening to all the campaign
promises
whether you're a democrat a republican
an independent or
whatever else they're all making
promises right now
and the one thing we can be sure of is
they're not going to keep most of them
them being politicians
and there's some systems that are a
little bit like politics that it's the
promises you make
and the plans you make that get you
ahead so that's the bad news
the good news is okay so so what are the
characteristics of leaders and
organizations
that link top talk in action so there's
a couple of examples here on the slide
but
to sort of back up to silicon valley if
you look at
many of our famous present and past
leaders well
steve jobs certainly the late steve jobs
is certainly one of them
larry ellison bill gates now chairman
but heavily um
or at least heavily involved in his in
his firm still
um balmer he's kind of go down the list
another a weird one
men's warehouse george zimmer one of one
of our heroes those you know who men's
warehouse is
uh the folks who run pixar um
like john lasseter there's a wide range
of personalities there
but all of them are the same in that
they are deeply involved as both
founders and
uh technically competent people um or
used to be in the case of jobs that they
actually understand
the work they're leading and therefore
they're harder to fool and to give you
the two examples we're talking about
here one of the great turnarounds in
american industry was done by anne
mulcahy
at xerox she's to me the anti-carly
farina i hope i'm not insulting anybody
by saying that
but um anne grew up in xerox she was
there for 25 years
uh before she became ceo and she really
really understood the details of the
heart and soul of the company
and um and that i believe was one of the
reasons that she was able to do such
really a stunning job of
turning around a nearly dead company and
conversely there's sort of the question
of
what do you do if you take over a
company and you don't understand the
technology the people and so on
and or the customers and a great example
is bill george
who's now a professor at harvard
business school but he had a few jobs
before that
including being ceo medtronic and he
brought them from a two billion dollar
to a 60
billion dollar company and and one of
the cool things bill did when he was
president before he was ceo they brought
him in
he spent 75 percent of his time this is
by his own report i've talked about this
several times
75 of his time um actually in hospitals
because this is a medical device company
talking to families talking to surgeons
watching doctors
um implant the various medtronic devices
doing all sorts of things that
to understand the nature of the
customers the nature of the product that
he was actually
selling and um
thank you and um okay thank you very
much
what something just happened okay
all right so so that's one of the first
causes of turning um
knowledge into action um the the second
um the second sort of um sort of cure
to when you're having trouble where
there's a gap between
knowing and doing is the complaint
problem now a little bit of what i would
call recreational bitching every now and
then
is is not a bad idea because we all have
to let off steam
but when complaints reach the point
where it's actually a sign
of pure contempt then it actually can be
quite poisonous
and and one of my favorite examples of
an executive or actually a manager who
eliminated this
there's a woman who i did extensive
interviews with some years back when
we're writing the knowing doing gap
and her name is annette kyle and then
after this amazing job
of turning around what was essentially a
loading dock that was ran by something
that was called the selling east
corporation it actually
they eventually covered it over but for
years she did a great turnaround
and and what happened was that
one morning she just got tired of all
the complaints and all the whining and
so
on so ann being a very action oriented
person
what she did was she snuck in in the
middle of the night and there were 60
guys who worked for her
and she sewed you can see the picture
these no whining
patches on their fireproof uniforms that
they wore
and she gathered together the people she
led these 60 sort of guys and she said
so the amount of complaining that we
have right now is actually
quite poisonous and um
and we would appreciate if um
when something goes wrong we being the
management if number one you could try
to fix it yourself
number two if you can't fix it come to
us management and we will help you
and number three if none of us can
figure out how
to fix it let's not complain about it
because it's just poison
and she said was actually quite
effective for stopping the complaint
so that's kind of like a second one and
it's kind of a cute one
but you really do need to be careful
about creating and fueling a culture of
complaint
another point is a simplicity one of the
things that i love during the period
that our banking executives to be
negative
we're running our um our financial
system of the ground and even
even understand the products that they
were selling many of them or at least
they claim not to understand them if you
look at their testimony to congress
one of the most successful uh ceos in
the united states
was a guy named a.g lafley and his motto
while he was running uh procter gamble
he had a brilliant turnaround
was the idea of i keep it sesame street
simple
and from having talked to a.g several
times
he always joked about what a boring ceo
he was
and how he would say the same thing over
and over
again until it was done things like uh
the customer's boss would actually be
an example of that and to bring this
down into
into a real situation of how this is
also done
also related to this is the notion that
simple strategies are easier to execute
there's quite a bit of research on
organizational strategy and one school
of organizational strategy
shows that or argues that you should
make your strategy as complicated as
possible so
your competitors can't copy it
but the problem with that logic is if
you make it too complicated your people
can't understand it
and and to give you um an example
um when steve jobs took over as then
acting ceo in 1997 what he did was he
walked around
the company and you notice they did this
huge pile of hardware and software
and he asked questions like why would i
buy and perform a 5400 versus
an 8600 and and as the um
as the quote says they couldn't even
tell their friends which ones to buy it
was so complicated
so in jobsd in fashion what he did
was within a year all of these products
were gone and he went to a simple 2x2
laptop desktop home office
and this was something that really
helped with this execution
to bring this into the present day and i
hope i'm not insulting my friends from
hewlett packard
but i recently got on the hewlett
packard website and tried to figure out
which printer to buy
i challenge anybody from hewlett packard
to get on the website to try to
understand the logic among
the myriad of products that you folks
have you guys have to do something about
this it is a serious problem so this is
a problem that we see
in an organization that's struggling
right now and it's something that i
think they could fix
um so that's the first point this notion
that you that to turn knowledge into
action you've got to find ways to bridge
the talk betw
the gap between smart talk and smart
action it's about knowledge it's about
simplicity
it's about getting rid of the negative
emotions but that's not the only thing
that interferes with turning knowledge
and actions
although in a lot of ways it's more fun
to talk about the smart talk trap
um one of the most important ones and
ones that we've seen in organizations
over and over again
are situations where essentially friends
turn into enemies and if you look at the
picture what the picture is
it's like like these guys are sort of
beating themselves to death
with these sticks in an attempt to get
the carrots and a lot of organizations
unwittingly create
a situation where instead of
treating outside organizations as
competitors they treat one another
as the enemy with the reward systems and
other cultural
elements um so let me give you one
example
from a now defunct company but still one
of my favorite and most amazing stories
there was a point about 2000
2001 where a guy named james halden
uh was ceo of conk usa and they brought
him in
and he really believed that you should
have competition in fact you have this
great line
at one point which was you should treat
your co-workers like your enemy
and he actually enacted this philosophy
he did this sort of like amazing thing
he'd have these uh quarterly meetings of
his regional
managers so these were the people to
whom multiple stores reported to
and um and what he did do is he would
sort of bring them into a room and the
first thing he would do
is the line says he would actually draw
a line down the table the conference
table and
if you were in the bottom half of
products
of profits you had to sit in front of
the line because you had to listen to
what he had to say
and and so that's creating this sort of
competition and the other thing
that he did was on their badges like
their badges i don't know i'm joe smith
i run the atlanta region or something
he would put their shrink numbers and
that's lost
and stolen inventory and and so and he
said oh by the way in the article that i
got this from he said that if you had
good shrink numbers
you wouldn't talk to somebody with bad
trick numbers they would be like a
pariah
and if you think about this well the
competition might energize people some
and i guess that's good
but the problem with it is that if you
actually want learning and sharing your
best practices
and treating the company is it as
joining the arms together in a whole
this is exactly
not the way to do it all right
so that's one example um another
and so so in in your own organization
your own life so you may have seen this
yourself like one of the organizations i
worked with
they actually completely undermined very
quickly the creativity on one team
by having a boss who would give people
cash bonuses
for developing ideas in a brainstorming
session so they stopped cooperating so
you can do that very quickly
so what are those some of the ways to
avert internal competition
there's a great line where you look at
research uh by organizational
sociologists uh also a lot of theory too
that out group threat creates in-group
cooperation or or bonds people together
so the notion of finding a common enemy
is one of the most
sort of constructive things you can do
we've got the example here of firefox
and microsoft many of you will know
especially in the early days now they're
turning into a more normal company in
some way
so although they're they're still a
non-profit actually a non-profit that's
owned
a for-profit owned by a non-profit but
anyhow that firefox the open source
browser
by sort of declaring war and microsoft
it got everybody energized and sort of
bonded together against the evil empire
now i don't think microsoft's so easy
and so evil and they're looking for
other enemies
but this was straight out of the steve
jobs playbook he was always declaring
enemy on
other people as enemies other companies
it was google towards the end of his
life it was actually
um ibm early on in his career he always
had an
it was disney at one point he always had
some enemy he was
he was using to sort of bond people
together
another important thing for averting
destructive internal competition
is the question of of sort of who you
label and annoy is superstars and
on one hand you could do something a
good example would be the old merrell
lynch
where you literally reward people for um
stomping on
people on others on the way to the top
where it's a zero-sum game sort of
almost like a car race where your job is
to like push everybody out of the way
and win
or you can define the superstar as
somebody
who if you will not only has great
individual performance
but also helps the other people around
him or her
succeed and i've got a list of some of
the companies i know and i guess i've
worked in one way or another with all
these companies ido mckinsey
procter gamble pixar and ge they have
vastly different cultures general
electric for example a lot of ways is
very competitive internally competitive
but still the people who are viewed as
stars and all those companies
are people who help others succeed
rather than uh
sort of like stand in their way and a
good example of this
is a.g lastly had this philosophy of
essentially that cooperation information
sharing were so important that he didn't
even consider it in the compensation
decisions
he simply wouldn't promote people who
were too destructively internally
competitive
and to give you a little racier example
actually just talk to this guy again i
talk about once a year
named paul purcell so paul purcell is
ceo
of um of a company it's a privately held
company called baird
very successful financial services
company they're doing fantastically well
and so some of you may know i wrote a
book in 2007
and came on paper back in 2010 called
the no rule
and i was just astounded to read in the
fortune best company to work
for list some years back that paul
purcell
believed the success of his company had
to do with the no rule so
i actually within a couple weeks was on
the phone with him
and um and he said and this is a direct
quote he's approved it i just heard
him say it again last week during the
interview i tell them if i discover
they're an i'm going to fire
them
but upon probing to paul purcell and i
again i just talked about this last week
again
his perspective is that the people he
wants to get rid of it isn't just that
they're
impolite so much it's the people who
consistently put
their own needs ahead of the
organization ahead of clients and ahead
of their co-workers
so again this is consistent with this
crap this notion of sort of weeding out
rotten apples all right so we've got
one more sort of way to
turn knowledge into action to avoid the
problem of
smart talk and the smart talk trap
and um and what one of the things that
is a real hallmark of places that
suffer from the smart talk trap i'm
actually thinking an example would be
citibank under john reed
years ago sometimes you have to leave
your source paint these grand
visions and these in incredible
things that we're going to achieve and
that's actually an important part of
motivating people but where the failure
occurs
is when they don't focus on the little
steps required to get there and in fact
we've got quite a bit of research
that um that when leaders don't do that
people
freak out and freeze up because they're
supposed to be doing these great things
they don't know how to get there
and in fact there there is a great book
called the progress principle which i
recommend
by theresa mobley is the senior author
and essentially in a very rigorous
study she showed that it's the little
things that happen in the tiny moments
in life that help people get ahead
not this idea of sort of like um
this idea of just painting the big hairy
goals and then sort of leaving
um and and i think this point makes it
as well this notion that the best bosses
sort of
uh frame things as stepping stones or a
series of small
steps and let me tell you a little story
from a ceo i know who kind of
sort of shows both sides of this so this
was in early 2009
and many of you uh will remember and
many of us are so affected
by the financial meltdown and a lot of
companies including here in silicon
valley were doing
layoffs in this company had a situation
where because of a bunch of financial
problems
that the ceo and the cfo figured out
that if they didn't have a sales
campaign for their major product
that was 30 percent better than the year
before that they were going to have to
do a fairly massive layoff and
as i kind of implied earlier i should be
under the delusion that the top
management teams of large organizations
were mature adults but
my experience with them has now
dissuaded me from that
and this is an example what happened was
after she presented this goal
they all started freaking out yelling
and screaming at one another and the
room went out of control and so what she
did was she passed out post-it notes
little post-it notes and she said well
well let's try to see if we can break
this down
and she had them write on the post-it
notes the steps they would have to take
in order for this campaign
to be successful and pretty soon she had
more than 100 post-it notes
and she drew a line on the board and she
said well let's break in the easy ones
and hard ones so already she's broken
down the big perry goal into steps
but to further break it down she had
them focus on the easy steps
and and what happened was they calmed
down and started talking about how they
were going to accomplish those things
and with a couple of weeks within a
couple of weeks all those easy things
were accomplished
and then they moved on and they made a
lot of progress this isn't like
like sort of like a complete fairy tale
in the end it turned out they had to do
a moderate layoff not a huge layoff they
almost hit their goals
nonetheless to me that's a good sign of
a boss who is if you will is moving from
a big hairy goal
to breaking it down into small wins
all right so we got a few here until we
wrap up and then
and then maybe uh we'll we'll do some
questions in here from carissa
so a couple of um sort of closing points
one is and one thing that i like to joke
is i guess i've written
uh five and i'm working on my sixth
management book and if you want to avoid
reading all of them you can just focus
on this question
which is that um if if you look at um
what it takes to be innovative what it
takes to turn knowledge into action what
it actually takes to be creative
to create a fear an unfear-ridden
environment
the best single diagnostic question for
a leader or organization for me
is what happens when people fail
and and of course you know this mindset
if you create the sort of like fear
mindset
that uh trying is a first step towards
failure you're in trouble and
if you kind of break this stuff down on
one hand
some organizations and some leaders
create what i would call
a forgive and forget culture this is a
this is the culture that
my uh actually now i've had two
daughters do this
that my kids want when they wreck to
have their first car wreck
when they're teenagers they never want
to talk about it uh they just want us to
repair it um but
you gotta if you do that nobody's gonna
learn anything and there's no
accountability
the second approach which unfortunately
is common in too many companies and
organizations
is remember blame stigmatize humiliate
and kick
people out even for making small
mistakes well
uh that that may make i guess some of
the death spots out there feel better
but it creates a climate of fear where
people
are afraid to surface mistakes and in
fact there's evidence
that for example uh when nurses and
doctors create
nurse supervisors and doctors create
that situation
what it does is um it creates so much
fear that people won't admit subsequent
mistakes or try to help others correct
their mistakes
so the best approach if you can find a
way to do it is to create what
research on medical mistakes describes
as
a forgive and remember culture where
when mistakes happen you forgive
people you try to guide them you get
them to surface them
and also the reason this is important is
if they make the same mistakes over and
over again that's probably a sign they
should be
doing something else so that's my first
parting point
for turning knowledge into action
um uh my sec my second one some updating
this
oh there we go my second parting point
and
and is one that's very important for
turning knowledge in action
and for management in general that there
was an interesting
body of research done by a guy named rob
cross at the university of virginia
and he looked at a whole bunch of things
using a technique called social network
analysis
that helped that that predicted um which
bosses would get ahead and which ones
wouldn't
um and who would get the most positive
performance evaluations a whole bunch of
other outcomes who would be
leading the most innovative teams and um
and um colleagues and stuff and
he ended up asking this really simple
question which is after you talk to this
person
you um do you have more or less energy
he asked some of the people who work
with them
and what he discovered from this
research was this was the strongest
predictor of those things so
i sort of leave you with this because if
you're going to create an organization
where people take creative ideas and
actually implement them
it's your job to sort of keep that daily
energy going
and you might want to think about how
people feel after they talk
to you and just as a footnote this is
not an argument for charisma
or for being exciting what this is
is is an argument for understanding the
perspective of the people you lead so
you know what it takes to motivate them
okay so with that i'm done with my uh
my i guess formal presentation and we're
moving on to the next phase
so thanks so much bob um
my name is chris little and i'm the
director of programs here at the
stanford center for professional
development
we've been delivering distance and
continuing education
to folks in industry for over 40 years
and so we have pretty good experience in
crafting programs that resonate and i
just want to take a moment to really
thank bob for his comments i learned
something every time i
i said in one of bob's lectures and he
takes lots of complex research and
and really boils it down to very simple
questions and tools and techniques that
you can take away and do something with
as a leader and so that's very exciting
one of the things that that i want to
just talk about
next here is that we partnered with bob
as the academic director to launch a new
certificate
with our center and with the graduate
school of business called innovation and
entrepreneurship
um what's great about this is it's an
online only certificate
and um what what's interesting is that
there's no one else out there that's
offering something like this and so
you'll get the best thinking and
innovation and entrepreneurship
from the school of engineering at
stanford the management science and
engineering department at stanford where
bob sits
as well as our colleagues over in the
graduate school of business and so it's
really
an exciting opportunity and i also
wanted to talk just a little bit about
some
some details about the certificate um
some of the really unique aspects of it
so what's great is you can you can take
the lectures entirely online
and do them sort of at a self-paced rate
but you could also do this with some
colleagues and groups if you chose to do
so
we've created a new uh user interface
for those of us who
for those of you who have taken courses
with us before um so it's quite exciting
and and so we encourage you to get in
there and give us feedback
um and the exercises and assignments
that are there
um are really um it's a highly produced
experience there's lots of interactivity
and lots of
assignments that you have to actually go
off and do something
rather than just consuming content i
mean we'll have some ta sessions
to provide feedback on assignments as
well as you can tune in and get feedback
live and so it's a different experience
than we've had in the past
a couple of opportunities to come to the
stanford campus we have the innovation
masters series that's happening in
december
we for anyone that's interested in a ca
and an on campus experience this is a
nice
opportunity this course will count as a
course towards the certificate program
um it's sort of a special elective that
we're that we're offering
um through our colleagues um and the
center for design research um
and it's kind of like a best of uh in
terms of
design thinking and the art of
innovation
so i just wanted to take a moment before
we get to some questions and answers
here
i want to encourage folks at the moment
uh before we finish this poll to
write in some questions because i'm
going to facilitate a q a session with
bob
in just a couple of minutes um if you
could take a moment to indicate your
interest
in the innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate that i just talked about we
would really appreciate your feedback
um it's something that we um we take
very seriously
and we'll keep the polls open for a few
moments while we bring up some
some questions that i'd like to
facilitate with bob
so let's take one question here
um
so what is the best approach in terms of
implementing
innovation with very little
or minimum initial capital within an
organization
um so that's interesting interesting
well it depends on the organization if
you're a little startup
none of them have any money so they just
start doing it
um and and my my perspective is
related to that and there's a whole
philosophy around this uh
lean startup would is is the epitome of
it but it's been going on for a long
time of just being scrappy and going out
there and finding cheap ways to test
your prototype
um so that's sort of like like the the
entrepreneurship approach
the other thing and there is sort of a
line between
implementation and creativity the other
thing is
in large organizations a lot of times
people i see you have an impact
if they have time or space or some way
or another
they just start doing it themselves and
there's this great there's this woman i
know and if i mention the name of the
company i'm not allowed to say name the
company you wouldn't believe this was
the company
who wants to um instill design thinking
in her company
because she thinks that the customer
service in their stores is degenerating
and so what did she do she didn't
start going to her boss she didn't
ask for resources she just made her
workspace
um an example of what design thinking
would look like
and now she's teaching workshops all
over the world this company
and this by the way only started about
two or three months ago and it's
actually
because because their concern is that
they're actually losing empathy for the
people who
will walk in the store so to me this is
actually an innovative idea and using
design thinking is awesome
innovative it's actually starting to
change just three months later
some of the things they're doing when
you walk in the store so they have more
empathy for how you feel when you walk
in
and to me now this is an extreme case of
somebody who is not a high level
employee by the way
and the way she said it is she started
doing it at
her desk but now that's not always
possible
there's some other organizations i would
by the way say including this one where
an individual can't always have that
much influence
and and and there's a reason that we say
it's sort of the knowing doing gap or
creativity plus implementation
that before you're going to start
spreading something
you've got to have something reasonably
good to spread so
so when i show you the example of the
roundabout at stanford
uh that's actually sort of cool and
something they did in a day
but most of life it's more complicated
than that before you have something good
to spread you've got to spend more time
developing it
but that's a great question an
implementation ain't easy
that's for sure um so another great
question here is how might a mid-level
manager use your advice to effect change
when top management operates very
differently from the examples that you
shared
so so i guess this is advice for
would-be revolutionary and deviants
and and my my perspective on that i
don't know the culture of your
organization
but my perspective on that is is there
sort of
i sort of do the analysis which is okay
so if i start doing it right away
do i get fired in trouble and so on in
that case what you probably got to do
if the price is too high of deviance if
you will for being a revolutionary
you kind of have two choices either have
to leave and start it on your own
or you've got to start building the
little coalition where it actually can
happen
um so so that so that's one sort of case
but there's some organizations
in not just the ones that have like the
15 rule
or 20 rule like google or 3m where you
can sort of do stuff in a corner and
nobody'll notice or you won't get caught
and there's one in particular there's
one large german company actually that i
worked with where this was the motto
where they
they would do what they called the
submarine motto which is the way that
innovation got done
is you go below the surface and sort of
take a team with you and maybe get an
executive sponsor to cover for you
and nobody would admit you were actually
doing it and if you failed then kind of
everybody would die beneath the surface
and nobody would mention it
but if you succeeded what you would do
would be sort of surface and then your
executive sponsor would take some credit
for it
and he or she would go to his or her
boss and they would take credit for it
and so i guess the point that i'm trying
to make is you've got to look at the
risk that you face
you've got to look at the organizational
culture you're in
and and you've kind of also got to do
the calculation which is
is it worth it for me and
and and we all have different sort of
risk preferences in our
in our different cultures but but the
fact is you know i always like to talk
about revolutionaries gary hamill wrote
a book about corporate revolutionaries
and celebrated all these people
it's important to remember that the fate
of most revolutionaries is they end up
getting shot
so it's always good to have a backup
plan
that's great um so a somewhat related
question is
you know typically upper management
loves aggressive managers or sort of
type a managers but they're actually not
necessarily good for innovation do you
have any thoughts on this
oh so that's a great yeah so there's
even some great research by this guy
adam
grant who's so this guy this is my
nomination for the next
business management superstar adam's
like all 32 years old he's a
toys total star and he's been doing some
research that show that essentially
groups will tend to report to put the
aggressive extroverts in charge
those people tend to nominate but the
ones that actually have
calmer more measured introverts tend to
be more successful because they don't
suck all the oxygen out of the room
basically so
you do have you do have a point in in my
my perspective
on that is in the end what you got to do
is kind of wear them down
and um and eventually and this is in
fact adam's even even doing a
got a book that he just finished on
altruism that's amazing
which is that he shows that in the short
term the aggressive
non-altruistic people are the people get
ahead initially who take everything from
themselves
but if you play the long-term game
especially if they don't get screwed by
the people who are what he calls takers
and they know how to deal with them that
they tend to win in the long term
so i guess my answer to that is if
you're in an organization
or in a setting where a long-term game
is possible
it'll probably work but if you're in a
setting where they have a very
short-term focus probably being the
aggressive
overbearing type is probably the most
effective way so part of it
is picking is picking your context and
yes
you know i hate to admit it but but
there are many times in life by being
loud and overbearing
that you do gain at least a short-term
advantages so for those of you who are
sort of like the more pushy aggressive
charismatic type
uh going into situations where there's a
short-term payoff is what you should
look for
maybe that's why most venture capitals
are so obnoxious in silicon valley
hope none of your venture capital
friends are tuned in
so it sounds like a knowing doing gap
analysis will determine an
organization's readiness for
implementation
of some idea or creative notion
um as in your stanford bike safety
example
are there any tools that can help you do
this to determine your readiness
so so my so that's an interesting
question
my question about that is there's two
things i would look first of all it's
almost like a frustration index
which is like the more frustrated people
are
so you want to be frustrated and
impatient but you don't want them to be
depressed
so so it's that i want to do it i just
can't
stand it anymore versus
versus the situation when people are
depressed it's really a problem
because they start losing hope and you
know you know i hate to say this and
you know i mean one of our clients
probably but i you know it's like they
know it too
i think that this is a problem that you
look packard has because everybody know
for
who works for you the packard is losing
hope and i actually think meg whitman's
got one of the hardest jobs on earth
and restoring hope in in turning that
what used to be an impatience and
frustration
um turning it to that rather than sort
of like depression and hopelessness is
really sort of the key so
so when people are sort of edging to go
that's when it really counts i mean
a good example of this and it's too easy
an example but it's a fun one
is i always like to talk about brad bird
who is the academy award-winning
director at pixar
of ratatouille and most famously
probably the incredibles
when they brought him so is steve jobs
and cat mill
and john lasseter when they brought him
um into pixar and told him to shake
things up
he actually made the incredibles with
what he called the black
he called them the black sheep they were
the people who were just pissed off at
pixar who thought that
everything was wrong they were ready to
quit but they had that fire in the belly
that it takes to close the knowing doing
gap and in fact
i i guess the the key here
is finding ways to create and harness
energy is good
and having people who are mad is
sometimes really good
the worst thing to me is when they're
depressed because i'm depressed they
kind of don't want to do anything so if
they're depressed try to make them mad i
guess
that's great um so i i think that's
about all the time we have in terms of
questions
um but i just wanted to make mention
that if you'd like to hear more
uh from bob we're launching his leading
innovation course as a part of the
innovation
entrepreneurship certificate in october
so stay tuned for that
i'm going to turn it over to roni who
has a few uh closing announcements that
she would like to share with you
thank you karissa so we'd like to just
let you know of a few upcoming
innovation offerings that we have here
with the stanford center for
professional development
we will have one webinar on innovation
on
october 18th at 9 00 a.m pacific
which will be given by some of the
faculty who are involved with our
innovation masters series
and we will have an a webinar in
november given by professor
hayagriva rao which is uh bob's partner
in
uh the academic direction of our new
certificate program
uh for innovation and entrepreneurship
and as carissa mentioned we're going to
have a new
course launch called leading innovation
by bob sutton and it will be launching
in october so i welcome all of you to
check out
our website create.stanford.edu to find
out more information about how you can
enroll
and apply for the certificate and lastly
uh we're going to have the innovation
master
series here on campus at stanford in
december
and you're well welcome as well to
enroll
for that uh unique opportunity so i want
to thank
all of you for uh spending this hour
with us uh please know that this
webinar was also recorded and you will
be receiving everyone who was enrolled
in the webinar
will be receiving a link to the
recording of the webinar
as well as the pdf of the slides that
bob shared with us
and thank you everyone for attending
you